hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played in 1998 in
a simultaneous exhibition that viktor
korchnoy held in
or torino depending on how you call it i
know some people who
call it tauren uh here in croatia we
call it torino i think also italians
call it torino
uh where victor korchnoy faced 30
opponents simultaneously and
out of those 30 games he won 28 and the
lost
two and i'm pretty sure uh you know
which which one we're going to show as
it's most interesting
so here uh he faces uh an opponent his
name is nikola voza and he was
rated around 1900 at the time i was
contacted actually by a friend of his
and he sent me this game and also some
additional information regarding this
game there's also a nice article in the
newspapers
uh with photos so i'm gonna share that
with you as well it's in italian so if
there are any of you who speak italian
it would be nice if you guys could
translate it for us in the comments
uh so i can pin it and show it to you
guys but getting to this game
uh a most exciting game that uh features
the folk beer gambit to the to the kings
gambit and also its game that lasted
only for seven moves so let's check it
out and see
why why this game so is so impressive so
uh victor uh with the white pieces uh
plays
e4 and for those of you who are maybe
new to chess uh when a grand master or
for that matter anyone else holds the
simultaneous exhibition he will have the
white pieces on all boards
so e4 we have e5 and here victor goes
for f4 this is the
the one of the greatest openings ever
this is called the king's gambit
uh where white wants to achieve very
rapid development by
uh for the moment uh gambiting a pawn
but black decides that he will not
be grabbing any material instead black
offers uh
a counter strike in the center and he
plays d5 and now there are
various ways you can approach this uh
but in the game i'm going to show you
some other ways that
are very nice but for this game viktor
decided to play
e captures on d5 and okay now you can
see
a lot of interesting moves for example
e4 is a very nice idea you could also
capture on f4
uh one of the idea is also c6 and c6
is what nikola prepared for this game
and uh
we even have a photo of this moment so
let me just share that with you guys so
i know not that not to that obviously
uh this is the photo of this moment so
you can see not that the board where
victor is currently making the move but
the board uh that he visited prior to
this one the one on the left
you can see that this position is on the
board black just played c6 and now
victor has to make
a full circle go back to that board and
then make his move and that's the move
that we are going to
uh to see now so let's just enjoy that
for a moment
there you can see some very nice
settings something uh
in the back there like a logo for an
automobile maybe
but okay uh getting back to the position
uh black just played c6 and he's
offering
this pawn for some rapid development so
here
victor played queen to e2 he's not
interested in this pawn he wants to play
queen captures an e5 and
deliver check so uh black allows this c
captures on d5 and now queen captures an
e5 with
check and now black is uh uh free to
play
a lot of moves black could play knights
the e7 maybe block this black could play
a queen to e7
uh but then you don't really achieve
much white just continues development
and you are hindering your own
development what do you what are you
doing with this bishop so after this
queen captures an e5 check
black actually played queen bishop to e7
and now it seems like uh the g7 pawn is
free for grabs but uh
that couldn't be uh further from the
truth and the
fact of the matter is that black's
position is much better here white
is even struggling to find the move here
i'm just going to show you uh what could
be played for example if
if the game continues with something
like knight to f3 white
just wants to finish development not a
problem knight to f6 and now if bishop
to b5
check you're just going to play knight
to c6 and now
black's position is still just better
you don't have a good move here for
white if you capture here then
you've only improved the black's
structure in the center here
and if you try and do something silly
like castle
then black will just play queen to b6
check and win your bishop on b5 so it's
a
very tricky position to play however
after this bishop the e7 move viktor
didn't go for
any of this uh victor actually grabbed
the pawn on g7
so queen captures on b and g7 now the
rook is being threatened
and of course black's next move is
pretty much forced black has to play
bishop to f6
and now the queen has to move and also
do rook is now defended so here victor
uh moved the queen to the only square
available because all of these squares
are covered by the pawns and bishops
victor played queen to g3 but it was in
this position that
nicola played bishop to h4 and
again it was in this position that
viktor korchnoy resigned in the game as
he just blundered his queen
so uh here you can see how rich the
opening is and how
great an opening this is that uh to
counter the king's gap
because the king's gambit is a very
aggressive opening and you can counter
it by being even more aggressive
with the folk bear counter gambit uh
although maybe okay it's not
um every day that you will see someone
play the king's gambit in maybe a
classical game but in bullet blitz uh
you know
it's being played all the time and i
will uh mention
i think it was in 2016 in the tata steel
tournament um
baskaran aliban actually used it against
the wesley so and got a draw with the
white pieces
so yeah it you still uh see it from time
to time even in top tier play
but this game uh completely wild so uh
we covered uh we covered some lines here
so let's just uh
as it's only seven moves e4 e5 f4 we go
for the king's gambit
uh black strikes with the d5 the fault
beer counter gambit and here
e cap e captures on d5 we have c6 now
uh reaching the position from the from
the newspapers uh
queen to e2 now going after the pawn and
here black just captures on the e5
check bishop to e7 and now queen
captures here
and that's it bishop to f6 the queen's
only escape is uh
you could throw in bishop to b5 cher but
just knight c6 it's not a problem
so queen to g3 and now bishop to h4 i
don't think i don't think
victor lost a game uh such as this one
ever in his life okay maybe not ever
maybe maybe when he was a kid but
definitely not uh since he became a
grandmaster
so really really exciting stuff and here
as i promised here is an article from
the
newspapers regarding this event so if
any of you uh
would be kind enough to translate this
for us in english i will pin your
comments so everyone else can see
uh i can see you know approximately what
is what is mentioned here but it does
say a lot something about
uh david defeating goliath and
well it'd be nice if someone could
translate this for us
uh but yeah and also i as this is such a
short game
i said i will show you another fun line
for example uh
e4 e5 f4 and d5 now going for the
fogbear's counter gambit uh y2 doesn't
have to capture anything white can just
continue development and now
uh black could go for d captures an e4
knight
captures on e5 and now bishop to c5
black also wants to get to some
rapid development in for example knight
to c3
knight to f6 black now wants the castle
and queen to e2 white wants to win this
pawn
and black says not a problem knight to
c6
and here uh you can see that the bishop
on c5 is undefended and it's a kind of a
common theme here and white could become
somewhat greedy and go for knight
captures on f7 here seems reasonable
because after king captures queen c4
check picks up the bishop
but black just plays queen to e7 here
and black
gives up a whole rook so white captures
that
and now white is just lost knights to d4
attacks the queen and now you really
don't have a good square for the queen
okay you could uh you could
uh try and uh create some problems for
black with knight to d5
uh attacking the the black queen forcing
this capture
and then going for some queen to h5
check ideas that is the way you could
prolong the game
but in short uh if you play something
like queen to d1
then the magic really happens knight to
f3 check
the king has no good squares if the king
goes to e2 then just bishop to g4
and then you're really threatening some
chaos here and of course if the knight
is captured then a discovery from the
queen
queen delivers check and there is no
good move here you have to block with
the bishop
but now you don't capture the bishop but
rather you play f2
check the king has only one square king
f1 and now bishop to h3 is checkmate
so really really uh a lot of fun that
this opening offers for black but
uh not not for white as you've seen here
uh as victor resigned the game after
bishop to h4 so uh how did this happen
how did a grand master lose the game uh
in only
seven moves to uh player rated as his
friend suggests some
1900 at the time or maybe even 700 uh i
i actually forgot uh but still i mean
you you don't lose a grand master
doesn't lose a game like this even if
he's playing against
another grand master so that doesn't
really matter
and what happened here i think is that
victor just decided that his opponent uh
was just making nonsense moves and then
uh after the
uh this position uh happened for example
this bishop d7 victor of course
saw that after queen captures on g7
black would block with bishop to f6
not allowing this capture but what
victor missed was that after the only
escape this bishop to h4 traps the queen
this is a mistake that will happen in a
grand master's life maybe once or twice
but here it did happen
and uh i mean what what a game i i've
never seen
uh such a beautiful miniature in the in
the fog beer counter gambit and i've
seen a lot of them
so hope you hope you guys enjoyed that
and uh yeah uh
if you guys have any hidden gems such as
this one where your friend
defeated like uh you know alejin or
maybe i don't know
bobby fisher or whoever you know feel
free to send them and we are going to
share them with everyone so so they too
can enjoy uh such a brilliancy
uh so yeah that's uh that's the game uh
like i said uh victor won uh 28 games
only lost the two this one
and another one that wasn't nearly as
short as this one it was a
pretty pretty pretty standard game uh so
yeah
once again hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank gabriel bagoon
sridhara rajagopalan uh alexander
weilhammer uh luke matkovic and argen
aslanyan for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and
whatever happens in the chess world so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day